nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportage long format de
France 24 en Équateur petit pays de 17
millions d'habitants l'avortement est
interdit et chaque année une centaine de
femmes sont poursuivies pour avoir
avorté celle qui en ont les moyens
peuvent interrompre leur grossesse pour
quelques centaines de dollars dans des
cliniques privées sans être inquiété
mais pour les autres plus modestes elles
n'ont souvent pas d'autres choix que de
garder leur enfant dans ce pays très
conservateur il est difficile d'échapper
à la pression sociale de la maternité au
militantisme des anti-avortement
pour reporter Justine sago et juaniaccio
Davila ont mené l'enquête en Équateur et
ont rencontré des dizaines de femmes
notez que ce film que vous allez
découvrir est lauréat du prix Coup de
pouce du figurafe Festival International
du grand reportage d'actualité Équateur
tu seras mère une coproduction France 24
[Musique]
match Atchi une campagne modeste au sud
de Quito
[Musique]
dans une de ces maisons une jeune fille
bouleversée ne sort presque plus de chez
elle parce qu'elle a peur d'être reconnu
Clara nous autorise à filmer uniquement
une partie de son visage sans pouvoir
identifier l'endroit où elle vit
à 16 ans elle est poursuivie en justice
pour avortement pour préparer son
audience un Avera son avocate viens voir
sa famille
[Musique]
ma fille avait des mots de ventre alors
je lui ai dit qu'il fallait l'emmener à
l'hôpital parce que je ne savais pas
quoi faire d'autre pour elle
alors quand nous sommes arrivés à
l'hôpital ils m'ont dit que c'était un
avortement
en avortement volontaire mais je me
disais ce n'est pas possible
alors un policier qui se trouvait là
s'approche et il demande au docteur
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe avec la jeune
fille et le médecin lui a dit que
c'était un avortement alors le policier
dit la fille va être emmenée
je ne pouvais pas me sentir bien en
ayant des policiers près de moi
et le moment où ils ont dit que j'allais
être arrêté
là ce que je ressentais c'était comme de
la peur
je me suis agenouillée devant les
policiers je leur ai demandé qu'il
n'envoie pas ma fille en prison
j'ai peur que la procédure légale soit
plus compliquée
et qu'il puisse y avoir d'autres choses
que je puisse me retrouver privé de ma
liberté
je pense que nous pouvons gagner
l'avantage c'est que tu finiras par être
déclaré innocente qu'elle est prise ou
non du miso prostol une pilule contrôlée
maux d'estomac couramment utilisé pour
avorter Anna a trouvé une stratégie de
défense elle va plaider une fausse
grossesse malgré la fécondation aucun
embryon ne se serait formé une anomalie
qui n'est pas rare mais au vu des
événements sa mère n'est pas confiante
la douleur en tant que mère n'est pas
partie
ce n'est pas facile d'oublier tout ce
que j'ai vécu avec ma fille ça a été le
plus horrible dans cet hôpital
la seule chose que je voudrais lui dire
c'est qu'elle me pardonne pour avoir
fait ce que j'ai fait
tu te sens coupable
oui
selon son avocate parce qu'elle est
mineure Clara risque maximum une
condamnation à deux mois de prison ou à
des travaux d'intérêt général
[Musique]
on Équateur petit pays de 17 millions
d'habitants l'avortement reste interdit
chaque année une centaine de femmes et
poursuivie pour avoir avorté
celles qui en ont les moyens
interrompent leur grossesse dans des
cliniques privées sans être inquiété les
plus modestes sont parfois dans le
viseur de la justice ou non souvent pas
d'autres choix que de garder leur enfant
dans ce pays très conservateur il est
difficile d'échapper à la pression
sociale de la maternité
[Musique]
à 50 km de là aquito des organisations
anti-avortement sillonnent les quartiers
populaires
aujourd'hui une camionnette vient
d'arriver devant une église
à l'intérieur des femmes viennent faire
gratuitement une échographie
[Musique]
ni gynécologue elle est anti-avortement
à l'extérieur en pleine rue l'examen de
la jeune fille est diffusé en direct
c'est Prouvy comme il se nomme sont en
campagne
ils font tout pour que les femmes
n'interromps pas leur grossesse comme
pour cette jeune fille sans emploi
enceinte de son troisième enfant
ici avorté en clinique privée coûte au
moins 400 dollars soit pratiquement le
montant du salaire minimum
le but fondamental c'est que les gens
comprennent que dans le ventre de la mer
il y a un enfant pas une tumeur pas un
amas de cellules et il faut que les gens
aient bien conscience de qui est
l'enfant qui va être avorté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un discours et une idéologie que partage
toute une partie de la population à 80%
catholique jusque dans les couloirs des
tribunaux qu'affrontent les femmes
soupçonnées d'avortement nous retrouvons
Anna vera cet avocate est une militante
elle a fait de la défense de ces femmes
indé combats de sa vie dans les bureaux
de son association surkuna elle accumule
les dossiers et dénonce parfois les
méthodes moralisatrices de certains
juges la pénalisation
de l'avortement répond si vous voulez à
un châtiment face au fait de ne pas
respecter une loi
d’être mère de comment être mère et
d'accepter les enfants que Dieu veut
quand Dieu le veut même si tu n'es pas
incondition j'ai eu l'affaire d'une
fille indigène qui s'était fait avorter
le juge a décidé qu'elle devait aller
dans un orphelinat pour développer son
instinct maternelle et on a tous les
préjugés combinés comme si les femmes
qui se faisaient avorter étaient des
monstres comme si c'était pas logique
elle voit des magistrats les condamnés
alors même que le dossier d'accusation
est falsifié
j'ai vu des choses terribles comme des
modifications de résultats d'autopsie ce
qui est un délit de fraude et des
changements de documents
j'ai vu des femmes condamnées à partir
d'une simple page consultée sur Internet
qui explique ce qui est une pilule sans
aucune preuve réelle car leur objectif
est de les mettre en prison et de les
déclarer coupable même sans aucune
preuve
poursuivi avec ou sans preuve
parmi les femmes qui ont connu la prison
pour avortement très rare sont celles
qui acceptent de raconter leur histoire
la plupart en ont honte et craignent
d'être montré du doigt
aujourd'hui Anna vient prendre des
nouvelles de Soraya il y a 5 ans
l'avocate la défendu
tout commence lorsque de violentes
douleurs au ventre la réveille en pleine
nuit
j'ai senti que mon ventre faisait du
bruit et j'ai senti comme quelque chose
qui descendait qui s'est décroché de moi
d'un coup
je me suis retournée pour regarder et
j'ai vu un bébé alors je l'ai pris et je
l'ai sorti de là et j'ai commencé à lui
faire des massages à lui tapoter le dos
Soraya a fait un déni de grossesse son
bébé ne survit pas elle perd
connaissance et se réveille à l'hôpital
les policiers et le médecin commencent
un interrogatoire
aujourd'hui je leur ai répondu non ils
essayaient de me faire dire des choses
de récolter des informations
j'ai dit docteur j'ai bu de l'eau avec
de l'origan mais ce n'était pas pour
avorter parce que je ne savais même pas
que j'étais enceinte
le jour suivant le procureur et deux
autres policiers sont revenus alors le
procureur a dit madame vous avez dit que
peut-être que vous aviez tué l'enfant
car il était sûrement d'un de vos
collègues de travail
je lui ai répondu mais j'ai jamais dit
ça et je travaille seulement avec mes
frères
trouver un mobile c'est ce que tente les
enquêteurs qui partent du principe qu'il
y a eu un avortement après deux jours à
l'hôpital Soraya est transféré en prison
le jour suivant quand je me suis levé
j'avais saigné partout jusque dans mon
dos beaucoup c'était une hémorragie
fatale qui me vide mon sang j'avais
tellement honte que je croisais les
jambes et un détenu je me souviens à dit
je sors bientôt de prison et si cette
femme meurt je dirais que vous êtes
responsable de sa mort parce que je vois
qu'elle ne va pas bien du tout
après 24 heures elle est enfin soignée
mais l'acharnement continue le procureur
va jusqu'à la poursuivre pour homicide
sur la base d'une démonstration douteuse
ce qui arrive c'est qu'ils ouvrent le
bébé ils prennent le poumon et le place
dans de l'eau si le poumon flotte il
suppose que le bébé a respirer alors la
femme est accusée de meurtre si le
poumon coule il n'a pas respiré alors
c'est un avortement le problème c'est
que le poumon peut flotter pour plein
d'autres raisons et nous avons de
nombreux experts internationaux qui
affirment que cette preuve ne devrait
pas être prise en compte au moins dans
un procès pénal à cause de la quantité
de faux positif qui existe
moi je restais seule et je pleurais je
pleurais beaucoup et tout ce que je
voulais c'était sortir sortir de la peu
importe quand je pleurais tout le temps
après six mois de détention Anna vera
obtient son acquittement Soraya n'y
avorter ni tué son enfant
très vite elle retombe enceinte c'est
grâce à Daniela sa fille qu'elle a pu
surmonter la douleur de cet injustice
elle me dit grâce à Dieu maman je suis à
tes côtés je suis ton ami
[Musique]
l'histoire de Soraya serait restée un
drame intime si un médecin ne l'avait
pas dénoncé pour les trois quarts de ces
femmes c'est dans l'enceinte même des
hôpitaux publics que les médecins font
le choix d'avertir la police
Akito Virginia Gomez elle-même docteur
milite depuis des années pour le droit à
l'avortement elle a vu le climat du
soupçon se répandre pour les patientes
qui font des fausses couches
arrivent avec des complications cela
fait généralement déjà plusieurs jours
le médicament n'est déjà plus dans le
corps alors comment hostile les dénoncer
c'est un grand rapport avec la religion
sur ce point les médecins sont très
religieux qu'ils soient de l'Église
catholique ou de l'église évangélique
ils sont très actifs contre les droits
sexuels et reproductifs
depuis que la criminalisation de
l'avortement a commencé le constat
qu'elle fait est très amer
comment en tant que féministe femme et
en tant que médecin nous sommes indignés
car nous voyons bien que le pouvoir du
médecin ou de la classe des médecins ou
de la classe professionnelle de la santé
et misogyne des tests les femmes il est
patriarcal macho en faisant passer un
message clair aux femmes
attention si vous vous faites avorter je
vous dénonce je peux vous traîner devant
la justice et vous faire mettre en
prison ce message n'est pas seulement
pour la femme en question il est pour
toutes les femmes
malgré le risque certaines n'ont plus
d'autres choix que de se rendre en
urgence dans les hôpitaux publics
dans cette maternité de la capitale
presque tous les mois
Rosset massacché gynécologue prend en
charge celles qui ont avorté et
subissent des complications lui ne
comprend pas ce qui se substitue à la
police
le médecin n'a pas le droit de dénoncer
professionnel
et ça c'est plus grave encore que de
dénoncer
ici rien qu'en 2019
400 femmes ont été accueillies à la
suite d'un avortement
certaines sont passées par des cabines
et clandestins car après trois mois de
grossesse une pilule ne suffit plus
il peut y avoir des infections des
hémorragies
il peut y avoir aussi des perforations
de l'utérus
ça mène à des maladies ou à la perte de
la fertilité et même à la perte de
l'utérus
on ne doit rien demander
juste faire notre travail qui est de
sauver la santé et la vie de ces femmes
ces femmes avortent dans l'ombre
souvent dans le plus grand secret
sans même en parler à leur famille
il y a deux ans
Sergio était loin d'imaginer ce que
traverser sa sœur
qui travaille là-bas à l'hôpital m'a
appelé et m'a dit que je devais m'y
rendre plus vite car ma sœur elle est
très mal
je suis arrivé à l'hôpital ils avaient
essayé de lui retirer l'utérus pour
tenter de stopper l'hémorragie qu'elle
avait
alors j'ai demandé au Docteur mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il m'a dit qu'il s'agissait d'un
avortement clandestin
elle avait trois perforations dans le
virus
45 minutes se sont écoulés donc je suis
allé frapper à la porte de la zone de
soins intensifs et le docteur est sorti
et il m'a dit
qu'il était vraiment désolé
[Musique]
avait 34 ans
elle vivait seule avec ses deux enfants
[Musique]
mon neveu et ma nièce
au début il ne comprenait pas
il pensait qu'elle allait rentrer
personne pour prendre soin d'eux ils ont
arrêté les études jusqu'à ce qu'on
puisse s'organiser on a dû payer les
psychologues car tout ça les a beaucoup
affectés
la famille porte plainte contre le
médecin qui a pratiqué l'avortement de
sa soeur mais malgré des preuves et des
témoignages accablants au procès il est
acquitté Sergio découvrira aussi
qu'alors que sa soeur agonisée un
médecin de l'hôpital l'avait dénoncé
avec surprise qu'une enquête était
ouverte contre ma soeur parce qu'elle
s'était fait avorter
pourquoi une personne qui est morte est
accusée quand le véritable coupable est
en liberté là dehors
la solution serait de dépénaliser
l'avortement parce que sinon
les femmes vont continuer à aller dans
ces cabinets clandestins
[Musique]
selon les données officielles chaque
année une trentaine de femmes subissent
le même sort
un chiffre sans doute sous-évalué car
certaines meurent avant de pouvoir
accéder au service de santé
à 30 km de là les produits arrivent à
l'église Santa Rosa pour une cérémonie
bien spéciale
la directrice de la Fondation emparo
Medina est à nouveau aux manettes avec
ses volontaires
c'est une adoption spirituelle des
parents
les parents adoptifs qui donnent des
noms aux bébés
des parents et un prénom pour chaque
cercueil
ils arrivent tout droit de la morgue de
la police nationale de Quito
[Musique]
à l'intérieur
se trouvent les fœtus de femmes qui ont
avorté
ces catholiques arrivent de plusieurs
villes du pays pour devenir
symboliquement leurs parents et leur
offrir des funérailles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'équateur est un état officiellement
laïque pourtant aujourd'hui ces
catholiques organisent l'enterrement de
17 fœtus avec la collaboration du
ministère public et de la police
nationale
nous avons essayé
par de nombreux moyens de retrouver les
proches pour pouvoir leur rendre leur
bébé
malheureusement nous n'avons pas réussi
mais nous sommes arrivés à cette
cérémonie ou enfin ces bébés auront le
destin que nous souhaitions depuis
longtemps
[Musique]
je ressemble beaucoup de douleurs car ce
sont des bébés qui sont des êtres
humains comme nous je sens que c'est un
enfant que j'aurais pu avoir à qui
j'aurais voulu donner tout l'amour du
monde
et je ne comprends pas mais j'imagine
que la pression des gens qui déshumanise
un bébé et disent que ce n'est qu'un
amas de cellules
c'est ce qui les pousse à prendre une
telle décision
mais ce n'est pas vrai c'est un bébé
c'est une personne qui sent qu'elle n'a
pas pu faire entendre ses cris dans le
ventre de sa mère
qui l'a tué de la façon la plus large
c'est avec ce genre d'action organisé
dans plusieurs villes du pays quand par
où Medina lutte contre ce qu'elle
qualifie de culture de la mort et
poussent très loin les comparaisons
cette façon de voir les êtres humains
comme quelque chose qu'il faut éliminer
pour différentes raisons nous ramène à
la Seconde Guerre mondiale quand des
gens qui se croyaient supérieurs à
d'autres croyaient qu'ils pouvaient tuer
pour n'importe quel raison
parce qu'il est le fruit d'un viol parce
qu'elle est pauvre parce qu'elle n'a pas
l'âge parce qu'elle voulait faire des
études
alors celui qui n'est pas dans ces plans
doit être éliminé
les difficultés dans la vie il faut les
surmonter je ne peux pas laisser dire
d'une personne oh la pauvre elle a été
violée passez-moi l'expression mais
c'est stupide
accepter son sort
en Équateur chaque jour 5 filles de
moins de 14 ans à couche des suites d'un
viol un fléau
pendant des années Anna vera et ses
camarades dans la rue pour demander à ce
qu'elle puisse avorter
en avril 2021 la Cour constitutionnelle
leur donne raison mais très vite les
députés conservateurs imposent des
délais restrictifs alors un Avera monta
la tribune de la santé
il est temps de faire l'histoire pour
les filles les femmes qui ont été
victimes et ont survécu au viol nous
exigeons une loi d'avortement en cas de
viol juste et réparatrice
poser des délaissez la clandestinité
c'est pousser celles qui les auront
dépassées à avorter clandestinement
mais pour le président Guillermo lasso
cette loi est encore trop permissive il
pose son veto présidentielle partiel ce
qui lui permet de fixer ses conditions
les victimes de viol n'auront que trois
mois pour avorter elles devront porter
plainte ou faire un examen médical qui
prouve l'agression
à l'assemblée a été si vous voulez
encore pire suite au veto du président
lasso
il a toujours été très conservateur
il fait partie de l'Opus di c'est un
homme absolument autoritaire qui fait
primer son point de vue personnel sur
les droits de la population
et la population
[Musique]
le combat d'Anna s'annonce encore très
long
en Équateur dans les milieux les plus
modestes l'avortement reste un sujet
tabou même pour celles qui ont principe
qui ont droit
[Musique]
à 150 km de la capitale à Santo Domingo
ce foyer de sœur bénédictine prend en
charge des filles mères placées par la
justice
[Musique]
sont tombés enceinte après un viol
certaines souffrent d'un handicap mental
comme Juliette 15 ans arrivé ici
enceinte de 6 mois
[Musique]
sondage mental son développement mental
et celui d'une enfant de 7 ans c'est une
enfant qui s'occupe d'un autre enfant
handicapé et victime de viol dans ce cas
la loi autorise l'avortement depuis
pratiquement un siècle pourtant les
médecins et la justice sont décidés à la
place de Juliette
personne n'a envisagé cette possibilité
pour moi c'est un peu absurde qu'une
personne avec un handicap
arrive à décider sur son avortement sur
cette possibilité de l'avortement
avorter sur le moment
peut solutionner le problème
alléger la douleur forte du traumatisme
émotionnel
mais cela ne nous assure pas que bientôt
cela ne va pas créer un autre
traumatisme qui est la culpabilité
et des dommages en tant qu'adulte
si elle réussit à analyser ce qui s'est
passé alors cette perte cet avortement
peut lui peser
[Musique]
la psychologue soutient que Juliette ne
peut pas comprendre ce qu'est un
avortement mais quelle serait tout de
même en mesure de s'en sentir coupable
une contradiction qui cache mal un
positionnement anti-avortement
[Musique]
sur les hauteurs de Quito les habitants
ont pour coutume de dire que la Vierge
tourne le dos au quartier les plus
pauvres de la ville
[Musique]
ces quartiers ou des femmes des cèdes
ou des filles élèvent des enfants non
désirés
et où d'autres encore sont condamnés
au nom de la morale
[Musique]
et voilà pour ce document signé Justine
sago et Roanne ignac
document lauréat du prix Coup de pouce
du figuras c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]